Hello, and welcome to Rawkode Live on the
Rawkode Academy.
Today is clustered.
We have a couple of clustered and a
couple of broken clusters and a couple of
great guests joining us today as we do
some live debugging to get these clusters back
online and working.
We have a clustered application written in Rust,
has a small database that we'll do our
best to fix.
Now a little bit housekeeping before we get
started. Please subscribe to the channel,
like, comment, and share the videos as well.
This helps other people find them. It keeps
the YouTube albums happy
and just means that more people get to
enjoy and learn together. We also have some
membership packages available on the academy that allow
you to support the channel, so please feel
free to check them out. And if you
have any questions, then you can jump into
the Discord and ask them. I'm more than
happy to tell you what we are doing.
The Discord is available at Rawkode.chat.
There's nearly 600 of us in there now
talking all things cloud native, Kubernetes, EBBF, and
everything in between. So come and say hello,
and I look forward to meeting you.
All right, last thing, our sponsor.
Teleport have been sponsoring us now for the
last two months, and I got to thank
them a whole lot.
It's the easiest decision I ever made when
it came to clustered because we use Teleport
every single week. We've been using Teleport since
the first episode, allows us to secure access
to the clusters as well as share and
pair in a same session,
which you're going to see us doing a
whole lot today.
It also allows you to expose those applications
securely through the proxy, which you'll also see
in action. So if you want to support
Clustard and Rockwood Live, check out Rawkode.live/teleport.
It's a UTM link, but I would really
appreciate it. And, of course, go install Teleport
on all your clusters. You'll thank me.
Alright. Let's jump over and say hello to
today's guests.
I'm joined by Rawkode Matt. Hey, guys. How
are you?
Good. Thanks.
Subly nervous yet?
No. Of course not. These are pros. These
are pros.
Alright. No. No. It's on both sides, I
think.
Alright.
Could you both do us a favor and
introduce yourselves? We'll start with Barco there and
then move over to Matt.
Hi. My name is Barco.
I'm a big fan of the clustered series
here. I think it's a great resource for
people learning Kubernetes or preparing for CKA.
So I'm really humbled to to participate.
I know I've learned a lot through this
series. I hope others find value here as
well.
Thank you very much. Matt?
Yeah. Hey. I'm Matt Turner.
Some kind of thing. Done a fair amount
of Kubernetes, I guess. I got my CKA,
which was quite a quite a stressful thing.
I I think this is gonna be worse.
I
haven't watched any of these because I didn't
want to
cheat. I mean, I didn't wanna end up
fucking somebody else's. It's a different time difficult
time time for me. I didn't wanna end
up just, you know, copying anybody else's breakages
by accident. It's hard to get them out
of your head. So, yeah, I'm I'm completely
new to this, but we'll we'll see.
Alright. Don't don't worry about it. It's all
in good fun. So I see Russell has
a beer. Enjoy, mate.
Pop has joined us. Rawkode, he's putting a
lot on your shoulders. He wants you to
make me cry. I'm just I'm just promised
he promised Tim Horton's copies, so I'm
gonna try not to disappoint.
Alright. Perfect. Well, I have Matt's cluster in
front of me. So we are gonna jump
over to our screen share.
I am going to open a session
onto the control plane node, and, Barco, I'm
gonna ask you to join and give us
an echo hello to let us know that
you're here. We're in the same terminal, and
then we will do our best to get
this application running as quickly as possible.
Let me start our timer.
Feel free to set up the KubeConfig,
and
we will check if we have a control
plan, which is usually a pretty good first
step.
So my I don't know how much I'm
I should troll you, although I should just
shut up. My worry here, to be honest,
I I haven't broken it hard enough for
for two pros like you. I wasn't sure
Sure. How close it would go.
This might this might be very quick, but
then we get to move on to Barco's
super hard, super broken cluster, and it's all
good. The the quicker is the I mean,
the sooner I get my dinner. Usually, I
meet dinner at 8PM on a Thursday. So,
you know, if I can get up there,
I'm not gonna complain.
Alright. Because I I put a list of
what I'll go through at the end of,
like, four or five ways I tried to
break it that didn't work
because I sort of, you know, came up
with them from first principles, but Kubernetes is
too resilient these days, and they actually didn't
have the effect I expected. So that was
quite interesting.
Alright. Well, it looks like we do not
have a control plan.
That's the correct IP,
I guess.
It definitely looks correct. I mean, I can't
say for sure, but I would I would
argue that, yes, that is probably the correct
IP.
And the port seems okay. Would you like
me to confirm somehow?
Okay.
Well, we don't have a server running.
Yeah. Or
okay. So
well, I just Nice reminder in the chat
from Kevin that there are only three rules.
Don't play teleport,
don't play with editing, no eBPF.
Although, the latter two are unofficial.
I was gonna say. Through rage induced
by me on previous episodes.
Okay. So
I guess cube controller seems to have been
played around with,
But
So we have the API server running, and
you've jumped straight into the static manifest. Right?
Yeah. I'm just going to see if anything
seems off here.
Same thing, Jamfi, too here.
No.
That looks like a perfectly normal
static manifest for the API server.
I'm pretty happy with that.
Okay.
I guess we can check
system d.
Yeah. Let's confirm if we have a Qiplit.
Russell's also saying there's a rule.
Yeah. That is a real rule.
We
have not invited to guy back after episode
two,
nor will they come back.
I see an API server there.
Maybe
it's just flapping?
Yeah.
Okay. That's Might wanna check out the the
logs perhaps.
Interesting.
Okay. So it seems to be restarting.
Okay.
Pause.
Haven't known Matt for a wee while now.
I would not be surprised if there's just
a doing a kill minus nine every three
seconds.
Yeah. That will you you know, no no
UTF eight, non blue cap. No
no product, and, yeah, I mean, the heavy
metal approach is is just something containers Big
cap. Would be your best bet.
I know you. It's more back here.
Simple but effective. Wait.
We don't have Varlog?
I have Varlog single.
Yes. Typing it wrong. Okay.
HCT.
Okay.
There's always a panic when I don't see
Etity running.
Yeah.
It it definitely shouldn't have lost its data.
Like, I haven't done anything like that to
you. You should when you get it back,
you should be able to upgrade in place.
Yeah.
I'm gonna have to find a way to
disable that, but there's always the remembered Vim
cursor every time we open a file and
it starts halfway through.
I I killed my bash history, but I
I've forgotten about that. Damn. Every week, we
see it. You're like, oh. Hacks.
Yeah. I didn't think of that. I'm obviously
I'm not a hacker, am I? I I
cleaned up my bash history.
All good.
What do we have?
I mean, this doesn't look right. Yeah. That
one m is is actually, he is never
gonna be able to start with that. That's
for sure. I can see a smirk on
your face, Matt.
It wasn't it wasn't actually crashing when I
left it. I wanted to just squeeze it.
I should have squeezed squeezed it to just
the point where it was
timing I
mean,
I would just remove
the the limits, to be honest, but we
don't need them.
We never follow that advice in production if
you're watching. But, you know, for for the
sake of clustered, am happy for us to
delete a little bit.
Alright.
We may just wanna give it thirty seconds,
make sure it's still
running, make sure API server is
up.
It's always fun to see which flags people
use with PS.
Mhmm. Everybody's got their own little unique take
into it.
Oh, come on, Russell. Six minutes thirty seconds
in and there's already a Rawkode smash of
just deleting stuff from manifest.
Yeah. They like to delete stuff.
But SSD dropped again. Right?
Well, API server is not starting up.
But that's oh, did did you Was that
CC still running?
Well,
I assumed it was.
Oh, it's okay. Seems to be running.
Okay. So let's check the logs again.
Yeah? Yeah. Yeah. Let's do it.
Let's
see.
There is multiple ones.
That's from five minutes ago, but I think
that's the other log.
K.
And Cubelet's
running.
HCD is running.
Oh, there we go. Server. There we go.
That
was
there we go. Okay.
So we have one worker that's now working.
That's good.
But we have control plane that seems to
be working and one worker that is okay.
Let's check few things.
Already checking for malicious
policies.
I mean I mean, I would maybe start
with the get pods. I'm just throwing that
out there.
Maybe it's running. Maybe maybe Matt forgot to
break it.
I I guess I'm just
You're just assuming the worst. Right?
Well, just kinda check what's next.
It's kinda difficult to know what to do
because I could've just r m this r
f the disk. Right? But it didn't seem
to be in the spirit of the rules.
So It's against the rules.
What's against the rules? Sorry. Deleting the disk
because that would kill Teleport.
Oh, yeah. Actually, you know, I could have
done something fairly dramatic,
I guess.
Man, I'm not doing very well here.
He's trying to delete all the pods. I
don't need to send I know. That was
just a complete mistake. I'm, like, thinking I'm
I'm thinking I have to smash everything.
Okay.
So
So we could ignore ambassador
mostly.
Okay.
We can see that our clustered pod has
completed,
which is not a good sign. And our
postgres are stuck in container creating.
And we got some silly and flaps too.
So Oh, there's our controller managers aren't running
either.
Okay.
Okay. Let's
controller manager. Yeah. I think the controller manager
is quite important. We we need that running
for everything else to reconcile.
Are you spot it? I hope I'd hope
you'd get to the point of
running the update, changing the deployment, and then
being like, where are my pods? Where are
my where are my pods?
Yes. Okay. Bear with I'm I'm 54 clusters
in at this point. You think I'm gonna
miss that?
No. I'm sure I'm not the most creative
person.
So that looks okay. And when we ran
the get pods, it was actually in a
status of pending, and pending really only means
one thing,
especially for a static pod which doesn't have
access to a lot of the Kubernetes primitives.
Did we have a scheduler running?
Yeah. Yeah. We may want to describe that
controller manager then and see.
Oh, wait. It's running now.
What's
Eleven seconds. That wasn't me. What are you
doing? There's, like, a lot of things are
restarting.
So I wonder
if there is something that's causing them
all to restart.
Yeah.
Old forgotten limit range.
Only known by open open shift operators.
Mhmm.
Yes.
Can you run get pods all again? I'm
I'm just curious if
we have more things restarting.
Okay. That controller manager does appear
to be alright.
Was it just maybe
at CD?
Like, I
don't know.
The fact that it was done.
So, yeah, it could be HCD related. So
let's assume it's okay just now, which means
we probably wanna focus on our clustered and
post code applications.
So,
I mean, our clustered and
complete, and we have one pending. What's
this web six x?
I think that's a decoy.
What
do you mean by deco? Like
I I think Matt has just deployed them
to
confuse us.
Russell asks, how can the clustered pod be
complete?
So it generally means that the process actually
is zero.
So it's either not our image. It's been
swapped out.
Yeah.
Hard to tell right now.
Was that the web one you described there?
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So that's just an engine
export,
I think.
I would suggest passing it. Just doing the
big delete button on it.
Nothing good ever came from random workloads in
my cluster.
I mean, it's
okay.
I'm gonna delete it, but I'm wondering what
responded.
Well, the pod name was interesting. Right? It
wasn't a pod tuple.
It's more of a
daemon set tuple.
I think he's just deployed a daemon set
called web. Yeah. There we go. Okay. Let's
delete that. Yeah.
Okay. Matt, you look sad about that.
That was my Tumblr.
Okay. I mean, we don't see any more
restarts,
I don't think. So that's yeah. You're right.
So
let's look at
let's look maybe
the image has been changed. I think we're
I think we're thinking that too.
Okay.
So
I guess I did
s t s.
What was it?
Okay.
Oracle's flying through this. I could just go
have my dinner and come back, you'll have
it fixed.
I
don't know. I'm I'm scared of that that
you see it's coming before.
Alright. Well, we're just about halfway through our
allotted time. So you've got just over twenty
minutes. You're doing well. You're doing very well.
So
I don't
am I missing something? I am not seeing
here request for limits.
Did they just pass through them?
You are correct. There's nothing in that manifest
that's setting the limits.
So what else could be modifying
them?
Another common thing, sensor to admission
webhooks or something. Yeah. Check the mutation webhook
configuration.
Me?
They're a breaker favorite on clustered.
Okay. They are.
Got the.
Oh, yeah.
EBPF for the control plane one.
We've had one EBPF breaks in the bar
that was brutal, absolutely brutal. Yeah. Know.
Okay. So there's not a mutating webhook.
So
I'm not a terrible person.
So what are you looking for now, Marco?
Can't you specify
web static webhooks like here? Oh, yes. You
can. So but there's only the enabled admission
plugins.
So it's only node restriction,
which is which is okay. Yeah. I don't
see anything. So I'm just thinking now what
are let's take a look at that here
again.
What was the error?
And you checked for quotas and limit ranges,
didn't you? And there was none. Yeah. Okay.
So
So can we see the request and
let me scroll up.
I actually
the node was low on resource of thermal
storage.
This may be something on one of the
worker notes instead. Yeah. Okay. So let's get
let's see something here. Me to open a
new session, or do you think you can
do it from the control plan?
One sec.
So
Okay. So it's scheduled on worker one.
Worker one is ready.
What if we just, like, delete it
and see if it gets rescheduled to work
or two? Is that gonna work?
Yeah. Go for it.
I mean, you could always
edit oh, well, we can come to that
later if we need to. Let's do it
this way first. Yeah.
Kevin says one of the workers was not
ready ready. Maybe it got scheduled there. It
appears Matt's worker has fixed itself. I'm not
sure how.
No. I'm not sure how. They're surprisingly resilient
things.
Oh,
is it gonna
what state was it in?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Navin's pointing out the
and are under resource issue, which we're looking
into now.
I was really tempted to break one.
I was really tempted to break the finalizers
just to just to really annoy you when
you're trying to delete things, but I didn't
get around to it. Sorry. I've got a
nice alias for that now called nuke from
orbit.
So that patches out all the finalizers.
Let's edit the deployment, Barco, and just add
node name to the spec.
And Well well, it's running now.
Oh, is it?
Yeah.
I'm not sure why,
but it seems to be okay.
So
Alright. Let's just go to cluster. The other
ones and see what happens.
Yeah. Go for it. Why not?
See, delete and fix these everything.
I know my chat are laughing at this,
but it does work.
I mean, we're gonna have to find out
what the breaks were because I feel like
we're
not really fixing
some of these issues. Like, I don't understand
what fixed the
Yeah. We'll we'll see what happens.
Running.
Okay.
Right. So when I upgrade it
to version two.
Yep.
Okay.
I think I'm gonna have to describe that.
Well, let's
just
I'm guessing the one that's running is
the old one.
Unscheduled
with no events.
I'm a little confused.
How's the bag? I'm just I'm I'm trying
to understand what's happened here. Okay. So
we have one running.
Is our scheduler flapping again?
Yeah.
We'll we'll take a look. Just
so this is
region one.
We do have a schedule there. Something's happening
with the resources,
I think, and they're
I wonder if I just do this.
It's Dean, the only one that works. That's
brave.
It came back as well. It did. It
did.
I assume this should be v two,
I hope.
Oh, no.
No. Because it's the replica set for the
old one is still active. So we have
an unhealthy new replica set with v two,
which can't be scheduled. So the old replica
set is continuing to schedule
pods.
Now our new replica set and the pods
created from is currently
pending. Now, that usually means that the scheduler
hasn't assigned a node
or a volume can't be mounted
or there are resource constraints.
Normally, we would see something in the events
for that, and we are not.
My
intuition is telling me
interesting.
Maybe look at the scheduler manifest. I don't
know if we did that yet.
It started at the top, so I'm gonna
trust that he's not modified it.
Maybe that first one was a red heron.
Maybe I am an elite hacker.
No. Our mission is, I mean, we don't
really need to fax anything that Matt's done.
Like, we can bypass the scheduler, which I'm
tempted for us to do just to see
if it works, and then we can always
try and work out what the issue is.
So as as you recall, Marco.
I'm just trying to think.
It seems like something's happening with the resources.
I'm trying to think what
what are the ways you can manipulate resources,
either available to Kubernetes from a node or
but,
like, we checked
we checked limit.
Did you describe worker one?
Like, describe the node for the API server?
I don't know if we did that.
Let's
let's check this and let's look at some
of the logs. And then if we don't
find something quickly there, we'll we'll try to,
I guess, your way
of just pass bypassing the scheduler.
Yeah. Look at that. We may have
a disk being filled somewhere.
And if I remember correctly at the start,
worker one was unready
was not ready.
So
sorry. And and, like, class, what did you
where are you looking at here?
So
we've got a warning about the disk space,
although it is a couple of hours old.
Oh, okay. But it does seem to be
okay as of nineteen minutes ago when we
like, because that was a not ready node,
and now it is ready, which is particularly
strange.
But that was the worker, not the control
plane.
Maybe we should jump on to worker one
and
Oh, right. Walk around? Yeah.
Let's let's do that.
Okay. I've opened the session. Feel free just
to jump in.
We've got ten minutes.
But I see we have we we snoop
around for five more, and then we bypass
the scheduler
Just because it'll kill me if I see
Matt wins.
Should've
brought a wee dram to just
it's almost 6¢.
So if you're on a a DF, does
the desk look okay?
It does indeed.
Do wanna add a dash I just to
check the I nodes?
Yes. Signed. Okay.
I'm assuming you had something running on that
node at some point, Matt, that was
doing something nefarious with the disk. Right?
Yeah. Yeah. I'll, yeah, I'll give it away.
I was that's why I think access to
node two is is lost. So I I
I tried to break both nodes. I logged
out of two and couldn't get back in.
I realized I'd broken it a bit too
hard. I still had a shell on node
one, so I undid
the thing that was in the. Okay.
Yeah. So that actually is a red herring,
I actually can't explain why the thing's still
having issues. Well, I mean, I did another
couple I did another couple of things on
the notes, but it's not I mean, it's
it's not that.
Okay.
So I'm confused. Are you saying that you're
expecting this replica set issues that we're having
that that's a different problem?
I can't remember exactly why.
What would we add up Yeah.
I think you are expecting
yeah. I think you are expecting what you're
seeing. Yeah.
Alright. Will we bypass the scheduler and then
work it out?
Or you you really wanna work it out?
I can tell. Okay.
No. I think you can you take it
over? I'm I'm kind of, like, stuck. So
I'll, like Well, let's edit the cluster deployment.
Right? And
we'll jump down to the pods back.
Straight out of the CKA, manual scheduling.
We're just gonna do a mod name.
One two one six five. Because it's a
So you wanna schedule it to a specific,
like, different node? Yeah. I'm just gonna hard
code it so we don't need the scheduler.
Like, I'm assuming that's why it's pending. One,
though. Sorry?
But wasn't it already in a work room
one? No. It's not scheduled to a node
yet.
The the new one isn't
Okay. I think
No. See, now it's container created. Is completely
wrong.
There was something the scheduler wasn't assigning a
node to it, and I don't know why.
But, like, we can just bypass it and
see if we get it working. And then,
like, yeah, now we I I
yes. Now I I for some reason, I
was thinking it wasn't
like, there was something wrong with that node,
but I I yeah. I I missed
missed it wasn't even being assigned. Yeah. Of
course. I mean, I have no idea why
the scheduler wasn't doing that.
But it was for the old rep, like
I said. It's really, like
yeah. I'm I'm not entirely sure what happened.
Shall we test our clustered application?
Yep.
Can you hear me say?
Aye.
Alright. So we cannot speak to Postgres.
So we're not done yet, and we have
seven minutes to go.
Okay.
I wonder which one of my hacks did
that
because this was all done in, I'm not
gonna lie, quite a compressed time frame. I
I I threw a couple of things at
the wall. Like, I'm glad one of them
worked.
Sorry. The the connection string is hard coded
here. Yeah. It just tries to speak to
the service Postgres.
So you wanna make sure that we have
that service that has endpoints, etcetera, just, you
know, basic
and and
see. So
we have postgres We do have an endpoint.
Yeah.
And then
So that's
that looks
okay.
Right?
Yep.
You've just been paged. It's 3AM. We're losing
a million dollars a minute.
Go. Go.
So okay. So
so the error message is it can't resolve
the host name.
Okay.
It
may be DNS.
In fact, this chat, it's
everybody's saying DNS. Russell, it's always DNS.
Naveen, it's almost DNS.
Kevin, even if it isn't DNS, it's always
DNS.
Why is it always DNS, though?
Because it sucks, and you should all use
Istio.
I've tried
it. I can't I can't get it installed.
Yeah. I had to I had to get
it in there. Yeah. You can be driving
up RAM.
Is running?
Now
if you've given me a cluster of this
tier, and we could have broken some things.
I'm,
fatty fatty pride at this one.
That's
correct. Right?
Yes.
So we see ready. We see Kubernetes cluster
.local.
I believe that looks alright.
Yeah. Good call. So we do have two
Kubernetes pods running.
Suggestions?
I don't know. Could be something on the
node.
So my suggestion
would be, let's get inside
cluster, get some debugging tools and see what
the hell we can work out.
Bash.
Yeah.
And then I have to every week, I
need to try and remember the name of
the package. I think it's DNS, you tells
no space.
Oh, for dig. Yeah. I always forget. Yeah.
I wanna I
dig.
Yeah. It's different than every distro. I always
forget. There's commandnotfound.com,
which is really useful. You just put in
the name of the CLI tool you want.
And for every distro, it gives you the
package name and, like, BSD and Darwin as
well. It's super useful.
Okay. So what deck is telling us here
oh, we're not using
cluster DNS.
This is the Equinix mail. DNS was over.
What's the IP address?
We
have it up here. Right?
I'm gonna
as we see,
1096010.
Yeah. Can remember.
But we can try and force the
Okay. So it did answer us
and that does work, but I don't think
a resolve.com
is using it.
So he's I'm super
impressed you found that.
Buried in the fourth line of fourth line
from the bomb.
So Very, very good.
Oh, it's
the kubelet configuration.
Right?
You want me to keep driving this barcode?
Do you wanna
No.
I'm I'm a little
not following actually what happened here.
Yes. So I'm gonna go on to the
control the worker node. Right? And we're gonna
do a cat of kubelet, and there's a
bunch of configuration files we can use. And
one of the things you can do with
the kubelet is change the DNS configuration.
If I can remember how
here.
I don't know if that's right or not.
And cluster DNS is here. What what I
thought he changed here
hadn't changed, but I feel like I'm close.
Ever since then So I guess
mean, we can check VarLib
kubect config.
Maybe there? I mean, he can't have just
done that really shitly.
Excuse my language.
Yeah. There we go.
There's DNS policy of default. I don't know
if that's correct, but I feel like it
should be cluster first.
And this is
Have I made that up?
Thirty seconds.
We might still restart it, don't we? Super
impressed. This integration won't get taken effect.
Super, super impressed. Yeah. The the pod had
rescheduled. The old one was still terminated, but
it was enough for the service to run.
So you you changed the cluster policy from
cluster first to default. Right?
Yeah. Because the default because this bit me
once, and I lost, like, a day to
it. The default is non default. I I
thought that would pass the eyeball test. I
thought you'd read that. I think the default
was what it was meant to be set
to. Did you think default would be the
default? But it's not. It's cluster first.
Yeah. Super impressive. The reason one of the
reasons they weren't scheduling is because the scheduler
is called default dash scheduler, and I changed
I overrode the scheduler to default.
So it would have been trying to be
using a nonexistent scheduler.
That's not the only reason either. But
There we go. Did you do anything with
the resources, or that was, like, completely off
there then?
Yeah. That was maybe a bit of a
red herring. So I tried to
fill the well, I did fill the disc
on both workers to
to get that disc pressure.
This cluster doesn't have auto tank turned on,
so I thought it would fill the disk.
It would get the disk pressure condition, which
it did, and then take the nodes and
evict everything. That didn't work because must
not do that by default.
But I did it by
dumping a load of stuff into a file.
And if you on the working nodes, if
you run t TMux attach, you'll find that
hidden in the background, there's just like a
a Python interpreter holding the file open. So
I made a massive file, opened it, and
then deleted the file. So if you use
d u, you will not find the file
that's filling the disk.
The problem was because I filled it right
up to the brim,
you couldn't fork a new shell, so I
broke SSH access. And like I said, I
managed to undo it on I thought that
was unfair, so I managed to undo it
on one of them but not the other
because I'd already logged out.
Okay. Well, it's great.
Yeah. If you there's also an anti affinity
between the clustered pods, which I think is
another reason it wasn't scheduling
based on a like, a global one. So
based on it, you can use any label
as the the topology key, and you meant
to use regional zone. I just used OS.
So because they're all Linux,
right, it tries to bring the new one
up before it turns the old one off,
but it can't do it because there's there's
no applicable nodes to post it on because
they've all they're all running the same OS.
Alright. Well well played, Matt. But we tried
to get it fixed. Solid team effort from
Rawkode and So
we're gonna swap
places now.
So I have let me jump back over
to our screen share.
I have Rawkode cluster here. Matt, please join
the session I'm about to open. There we
go. Just an echo hello. Let me know
that you're there. Barco, feel free to sit
back and relax and enjoy. Awesome. Thanks.
It's fun.
My invite code's expired. David, just want to
get another one.
You're supposed to register before the episode, Matt.
Come on. Wait. This is fine for four
hours. I only got the link two hours
ago.
Oh, yeah. It should be good then. Yeah.
The the the email I oh, never mind.
Doesn't matter. Oh, did I have to register
for bucket list as well? Okay. I thought
I'd registered once, and I could just connect,
so I didn't yeah. I didn't know anything.
Well, I guess this is a nice opportunity
to show everyone how easy it is to
add new users to Teleport. Alright?
Users add rules admin logins route empty.
Let's hope you get to this before anyone
in the audience does. Otherwise, they're pairing with
me and you get to go home.
I I stuck the link in our private
chat just to pop that open.
I'll just clear that. There we go.
The chat on
An e cam. Yeah.
Oh, that's the one. Yeah.
I should have started the timer when you
told me the link was broken, shouldn't I?
Yeah.
You can see it.
I think it's good. Let's see what we've
got in the chat. Russell with mission impossible
level timing. Nice work. Yeah. We did come
far too close. I've been saying the same.
Super impressed. Kevin, have a celebratory beer. I
I wish I don't actually have any.
I will not make that mistake again.
No. I should have brought one. I would
have taken
the edge off.
Clustered Rawkode.
Not quite consider myself lucky.
Alright.
Managed to register yet?
Yeah.
I thought
I was in.
Did you join my active session,
or did you open your own?
Correct.
I'm not very gonna be very good at
this, am I? You'll be fine. Let's just
get in the same session. Check out activity,
then active sessions.
There we are. Cool. I thought I could
show the audience that. So you join sessions
on Teleport by clicking activity,
active.
And now I can see that Matt opened
one. Okay. Yes. Feel free to join me.
Hi, Drew. Awesome.
Alright. Thank you.
So you're gonna have to export a cube
config, check for the control plane, and I
am gonna start our timer.
Okay.
Use whatever command you wish. I do appreciate
the key alias, though.
Uh-huh. Okay.
Interesting.
We're route.
It's allegedly
readable by its owner,
and there's no dot saying there's an SE
Linux context or an extended attributes on it.
Well, that's interesting, isn't it?
I mean, I would try LS after just
in case. But
I thought you would get a little thing
on
yeah. But okay. It's a fair point.
I haven't Well, yeah, I I'm gonna look
it up. I don't remember what the the
e is. Yeah. Do you mind? I haven't
heard of them. I haven't used the subsystem
for a while.
Oh.
But we
we can count it in QC. Okay. Interesting.
Can we install packages onto this thing?
Oh,
tell me what the letters mean.
You can always rely on the arch lit
arch Linux wiki. That's what exactly what we
need. Best thing. E is extend format. So
I think that's actually safe. So I I
don't think we need to worry about that.
Are you running an s trace?
Yeah. Why don't we see this? What
he's doing?
He's obviously doing some low level Linux nonsense.
Resource temporarily
unavailable.
Yeah.
What is
You wanna check the mount points?
Oh, maybe. Yeah.
Could have given us, like, a weird mount.
Read only file system over the top. That's
odd. Can we see the call to read
the environment?
No.
I
can't see the access to the environment variable
or
any any stat or any open call
on the file.
It doesn't
So let let's let's do the basics first
before we go into the deep dive stuff.
Like, is our kubectl really kubectl?
Yeah. I think it's I no. I think
it's forking.
Think it's forking.
Elf binary.
It's a go it's a go, but elf
binary.
It does look alright. Okay.
It was put there at a plausible time.
It's a plausible size.
Yep.
What have we how could you broken it
using this? Like, put a read only file
system over the top?
That was one of my thoughts too.
Yeah.
Yeah. It's meant remount
r o.
But that's errors. Right? So that's if there's
a file system error, it shouldn't Alright. It
shouldn't freeze it. It should remount it read
only, so I think that's okay. I can
see Barco laughing at us already.
I'm just laughing at the comments.
This
is that is a full
Google interview stuff.
Alright. I've got confidence in this.
So
It's not a SIM link. It's only got
one hard link.
Let's try and change the permissions on it
to seven four four and see if it
complains those. Right? But the thing the thing
is
we can cat it.
So something's stopping. KubeCTL
has, like, an SE Linux. Okay. I mean,
if there's I'm
gonna be angry. Like, it's like it's like
KubeCTL has got an SE Linux text or
something.
I don't know too much about on the
right track. It's nothing with the files.
It's something with the kubectl
command.
Correct.
Are you using eBPF?
I am not
I don't think
Oh, okay. I I cannot do anything with
eBPF now.
You're looking for LD preloads. Yeah.
Yeah. I'm seeing you there.
Okay. So if there's something to do with
a cube control command, we already validated this.
Right? Let's check, like so let's check if
it's an alias.
Run can type alias.
Adjust our alias. Okay. So
could be a function.
I don't
know because that would show up when we
did this. Right? And I did that to
find the file.
The file's okay. I'm gonna check anyway.
I mean, there's many places it could be,
but still Yeah.
I mean, that we could always just do.
That's true.
Okay. So it's something getting in the way
of
kubectl,
which looks
okay.
Mildly preloaded.
I'm thinking it's gonna be, like, a, yeah,
Systrace, like, of the security mechanisms. It's it's
gonna be gVisor or something, you something that
blocks syscalls.
Although I never saw when I s traced
it, I never saw
the access
to admin.com.
So I wonder what I mean, does does
it fork naturally?
I can make this thing follow forks f.
There we go. Okay. Forked.
I assume
that's natural.
Yeah. Access permission denied. Well, they got assume.
Barco's done some of the
maybe Barco's just opening the file at that
path. So why don't we copy it to
somewhere else and see if it works?
That's a good point.
Yeah.
There's a new one there, but I can't
see there's there's several pits, but I can't
see the
fork.
Oh, because it of it's called clone these
days.
I just wonder what on earth is
so where's it exec ing?
Because something we've seen on a previous episode
from Noel
was the
BPF
bypass that would restrict access to open a
certain files on the disk.
So I would suggest we just try and
copy it somewhere else. And if that doesn't
work, we need to start
exploring the processes on this machine for something
malicious.
Yeah. I'll tell you what we'll do. We'll
do that so it gets a new INED
number as well.
Poo.com.
That was the best name you came up
with.
I I
hold on. What do wanna call it?
Right. But remember, it it snapped with that
file. Now I'm curious if we copied kubectl
to a different
location.
That would work.
Okay. So we can't read anything.
That's interesting.
Yeah. Right. So, yeah, Kube CTL. I wonder
whether there's an SE Linux policy that's matching
the the loaded file.
Well, Kevin said in the chat that you
can't get SE Linux on Ubuntu. But someone
told me last week, you can now get
SE Linux on Ubuntu, and that put the
fear into me.
Hello.
Yeah.
Oh, that works.
Interesting.
That
was a good suggestion on my part.
App Armor. There is an AppArmor profile for
KubeCTL
that
doesn't allow you there's nothing in it, really.
It wasn't generated. It's just preventing you from
running the command.
Sneaky.
Nice.
Okay. That's AppArmor made the ban list. Alright.
Let's continue.
Yeah.
AppArmor and SD Linux are those things that
I really should learn better, and I've never
invested any time whatsoever.
No. Normally I mean, when I say SELinux
and people said it literally doesn't exist anymore,
that shows how much I know. But, you
know, one of those Linux security modules.
Oh, look. Okay
then.
Back to where we were.
It seems to be kind of running, but
they both my cluster was older than that,
so he's been in here since you did
something.
This all looks
good.
Oh, I don't have any of my illnesses.
This all looks suspiciously quiet except
the network's up and down all over the
place.
And, wow, so it's all of the control
plane.
Okay. So we don't have an APIs.
The API server's flapping because, obviously, it's been
up at some point because we can
we can do this. Yeah. What's the restart?
Should we just try it and see what
happens?
Yeah.
So what's the fix for the AppArmor thing
then, Borko? How would we fix it? You
can you
can just basically, there's a command,
a a log
prop.
Sorry.
Gen prop or something like that or log
prop
that will generate
the
the profile
AppArmor profile for kubectl
based on, like, the last time it was
executed, like, all the syscalls it needs, and
then it will allow you to do it.
Or you can just disable the profile itself,
and then it should work.
Nice.
Boot into sync mode.
We haven't seen our before.
Let's say, clustered first. Yeah. I've tried to
kind of because I've seen a few episodes.
I've tried to
put in things that I haven't seen before
just
to help people, I guess,
audience, like, get exposure to some things. I
don't know.
Because I I found this,
like, really useful to learn from, like, really
enlightening to see how people think and different
things they can think of breaking.
So
I try to put things that they haven't
seen before.
Alright. Awesome. Matt, we've got Angry Man, and
our authentication for Postgres failed.
Yeah. But you'll notice it's it's v one
Angry Man.
There really has no. There only has one
Angry Man. This is the v two image,
but we're getting an error connected to the
database. Oh, is it? I'm sure it's a
v one.
The the title of our web page is
v one. Oh, yes. Good. I I I
think that's cached.
Oh, okay. Great. There is a caching problem,
and sometimes I have to reload it 54
times before I get the new video. I
don't I I don't tend to open v
one anymore.
No. Fair enough.
Okay.
So we've upgraded with the and it can't
auth to Postgres.
That's interesting, isn't it? And then and the
whole control plane's flapping.
That's all very odd. Okay. How do you
wrote this app. How does the auth work?
Does it get its password from a config
man?
No. It's
it's hard coded.
Okay.
Postgres and Postgres one, two, three, if I
remember correctly. But you can you should be
able to take a look at the stateful
set, and it's just environment variables passed into
the Postgres image.
Well, now our now our API server.
There we go. We need to fix that
flapping.
Yeah.
Degraded.
It's a static manifest, so you won't find
out those?
We will still see it as a as
a child of containerd.service.
Right?
Except it's not there at the moment. But
okay.
Yeah. Let's do a quick quick visual inspection
of the
Why do people never look at where the
cursor is when they open the file?
Oh, no. I forgot. I was just just
spot where it was.
I see some sneaky stuff.
Okay.
And there's all kinds of things you could
subtly break in here.
Yeah. It looks like Oracle has added an
encryption provider to our API server.
So
You might wanna take a look in temp
e c e c.
Yeah. Embarrassing question. What does that even do?
That's the encryption at rest in etcd, right,
for, like, the raw encryption.
I believe so. Yes.
Yeah.
Now what we have to be careful with
here is
if we remove this,
we can't
can't read out an SCD anymore or he
could have added it and not actually enabled
the encryption on SCD, in which case this
is the reason it's flapping.
So what
we're gonna have to do is check the
API server logs, I think, and see if
we can get some information before we go
all Hulk smash on this. What if we
Hulk smash it and we just lose all
of that CD? We can just put it
back. Right? Because we don't need API server
access to do it. Yeah. Just don't delete
the ec.yaml.
Oh, no. No.
Mustard. You know, 123456.
Nice. I wonder if there's gonna be something
spicy in there.
I I tried to put it the the
the thing is you have to limit to
exactly, like, 16 or a certain number of
characters so you don't have much
much
room for creativity.
Oh, is it okay. I was gonna get
the logs through through QCTL through Containerboard. You'll
need to go to Firelog. Yeah. I'll I'll
tell you the restarting
is not passed by the encryption.
Okay. That's good to know. Okay.
Containers.
Yes. Where it is. Then, yeah, cube dash
API.
So where do we go?
No match.
Failed to list
config maps. Enable transfer.
This looks like some Nets CD.
Registry config maps default.
Keywords in. Machine. No machine prefix found.
This does look like it's it's looking for
a hard coded config map in NCD, and
the NCD
tree has been
mutilated.
Mm-mm.
Go back up. Is there any precursors?
That's just a reboot, isn't it?
Shutting down. Stop.
Shutting down. Shutting Shutting down. Shutting down.
Okay. We wanna check.
I mean, the STD is running because that's
why we'd see an error that it couldn't
actually.
STD is actually not flapping, is it?
Oh, I don't know. The only thing is
PS.
API server's going by. Yeah. Good. Yeah. One
time it's restarted, I guess.
We should be able to see the time
of the process started.
Seventy two minutes ago. Right?
Okay. Yeah. Right. So ACD is okay.
Does look like it's been
okay. So it looks like an important config
map is gone. We can't use the API
server to inspect it.
We could use ACD CTL.
Well, we do get an API server for
a while, so we could always wait for
it to restart, and then we're on a
clock. But maybe there's a nicer way to
do it.
Oh, it's back.
Yeah.
Get
config maps all.
Right.
Where did it does stuff for config maps
and not
pods? Why is it trying to get it
to CA
for one and not the other?
I don't understand that.
Little confused that k get c content apps
all did not work. I would have expected
that to work.
Okay. Yeah. I love it when have to
ask them. We
Wait.
What was the error when you ran that?
Something about
I'll show you.
Something about I love how you're joining to
fix this as well. Okay. None of those.
Try to get Centimeters again.
Unable to transform key. Right? Okay. So, yeah,
that does make sense, I think, actually.
Why? Yeah.
Because there's a few especially config maps. Right?
Out of the box, there's a few of
them that
are, like, completely intrinsic. And I think, you
know, because you could there's always a service
called Kubernetes, and there's always a config map,
I think, with the cluster c a in,
there's always just something else. And it looks
like he's maybe managed to delete it.
And, like, the error handling,
it's just always expected to be there. So
the error handling is just it just doesn't
really wrap it nicely, and it's saying, well,
I'm trying to get this because this is
this is the raw key in NCD. Right?
It keeps everything under slash registry in NCD
for some reason. So this is the raw
etcd path, and it's just saying it can't
can't find this or can't find some, you
know, some prefix of it. Yeah. So I
always use this to configure etcdctl.
Let's copy this.
Yes.
Cool. I can never remember how to do
that.
Okay.
What was it? Registry.
Yeah.
I don't know if I should be seeing
something or not. I'm not an entity. I
think we have to go
registry
slash the namespace
slash config maps or config maps slash namespace
one or the other? I forgot.
It's it's config maps slash namespace by the
looks of that error. There is a flag,
something like list resources or something like that
to show you the tree,
if I remember correctly. Yeah. There there was
some kind of, like, list commands in there.
This is my least least favorite part of
the CKA. Yeah. This is a bit intractable,
this NCD.
I don't remember NCD.
No. You might have to go
do want me to Google some stuff?
Well, we ran get registered services, and that
worked. Right? We actually got this value back.
I have an SCD cheat sheet. Right. So
because this one doesn't work. Right? So
why can't we do
config maps?
Where did specs come from? It was just
part of that thing.
I don't know how to show the tree,
so let's try that. Add to the CTL,
print tree.
So
I I should I start copying and pasting
from this cheat sheet? Oh, yeah. Go for
it. Fuck it.
Yeah. I don't I don't know what it
is.
Yeah. There we go. Alright. So Oh, yeah.
There we go. What's under config map?
Flash registry slash config map.
So we do have default kubrits here. Yeah.
But what's the error message again? I'm gonna
copy this. But
It's basically saying that doesn't exist.
Is that the same?
Did you copy a registry?
Nice.
He wouldn't do that to us, would he?
Is it u is it a UTF eight
hack?
They're not allowed?
No.
That actually looks alright. Okay. So
that's interesting.
I'm able to transform
key.
I assume we're reading this right. I mean,
to me, that just says it doesn't exist
in the database, but maybe that's
maybe there's more nuance to that error. Can
use the x c d
x c t l to check what it
what it the value is in there. Right?
Okay. Yeah. I was assuming that meant the
key didn't exist.
But, yeah, let's we could try to get
its value again.
You tried that, though, didn't you, David?
Yeah. But we weren't doing it right. So
I mean, I wasn't doing it right.
Looks like you said to me.
I mean, it might be garbage, but I
I like,
I'm not reading the I'm not reading the
error message.
The error message to me says, yeah, no
prefix found. It means that that path in
SCD doesn't exist.
But
Yeah. It is.
Gonna be something subtle, isn't it? So the
path exists.
Yeah. That other message is really shit. I'm
gonna Google it.
Yeah. Do it. Because I I SCD is
honestly my least favorite part in this. Can
you you try something else? Can you get
config maps from a different namespace?
Like
Interesting. Specific namespace?
Just cube c No. No. No. I mean
cube c t l.
Dash dash keys only.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Oh, we can. It's just the default namespace.
Okay. It's just black.
Alright. Well, it was I had fun, but
I'll see you later. I'll go home.
Wow. Okay.
What sits between the API server and entity?
Like, nothing that I'm
aware of.
And this isn't our like, if RBAC wasn't
allowing us, then it would be a much
more,
you know, friendly Kubernetes level error. Right?
The fact this is saying internal error, the
fact this is making it into the API
server's logs
means this isn't, you know, this this
is an exception. This this isn't, like, an
RBAC or anything.
I'm gonna take a look at this.
Which
namespace is that meant to be in?
Well, that is the cube system one. Right?
But that
what I'm worried Is it meant to be
in both?
I think it's in every namespace.
Oh, is it? Okay.
Oh, right. So that you can always get
it no matter what your RBAC is. Okay.
Are those the same?
Yes.
Maybe you should be I mean, I I
did a very simple test of the first
five and last five characters, but I'm gonna
assume,
that they are Oh, it's it's hash yeah.
It's hash algorithms go. That's like NSA proof.
So
Yeah. And it's I mean, they yeah. It's
there's a few because they're on the serialized
protos. Right? So there's you can see the
text. I think was winning a gift card
at this rate.
Yeah. This is this is awful. Whatever it
is.
Cannot transform me. Did you find anything on
the error message? Because what what's the transform
part about?
It is encryption related. You told us it
wasn't, Marco.
Yeah. Yeah. Restarts
aren't encryption related. No?
Alright. Okay. The restarts are due to this.
Issues with encryption. Yeah.
The the thing spams this into its logs
and then quit. Like, the restarts are due
to this. Surely. Surely.
Okay. I'm assuming you've enabled encryption,
but not you've you've not on this key
or you've put the old version of this
key back into.
I'm gonna assume
He's encrypted one namespace. Right? He's encrypted one
or the other because it works for one,
and it doesn't work. It's gonna let my
turn on. Oh, wait. It's done the scrolly
bug, hasn't it?
How on earth are we gonna undo that
in fifteen minutes? So I'm assuming he's maybe
been nice to us and left us
Yeah. I guess a script or
I wonder what he's done to Cilium with
Cilium's
deployment being in temp.
I wonder if we can just do
a get from
the cube system namespace. Right?
And store it into the default space. Yeah.
That's encrypt it. The other one is plain
text.
So we're gonna have to
in fact, let's take a look at the
default one one more time. Right? So
I don't think there's enough namespace
in it. Right? It's just a certificate. It's
just a metadata. So we can just write
the cube system one to the default key.
So Yeah. Right. Yeah. Okay. So encryption's on,
so it's trying to decipher everything, and the
one in default is not enciphered. So it's
it's deciphering the garbage or it's not checks
something or something. Okay. So this is the
o
This is our encrypted
secret.
But has he only encrypted
the one
everything else works. I know you're right. Encryption's
on, and we can read the pods, and
we can read the deployments and stuff. Right?
So we did yeah. Okay. I think everything
but one thing is encrypted.
So let's put
And that's a smart way to do it.
Right? Because we get the error on the
one that's unencrypted, and we inspect it with
etcd CTL, and it looks okay.
That's that's a very smart way to
send us down the wrong path. So how
do we
we can't interesting workaround. I mean, the the
solution is actually much easier than this. But,
like, oh, but
now I'm curious if this will work.
Let me get my cheat sheet up.
Well, let's try to read the default one
again.
Yeah. There should just be a put. You
should be able put. I've put it. Yeah.
Okay.
Alright. This is great. Awesome.
Scroll bug.
Oh, we've currently got it.
Okay. So we still need to fix the
flapping, but I think we might be able
to get all the config maps so that
API server comes back. So let's let's deal
with this flapping because that's getting made too
fucking annoying. Yeah. Okay. So this so that
encryption error was was filling up the logs.
So, yeah, let's try to find the flapping.
Grep dash v is your friend, I think.
Okay.
We'll just need to wait for that to
come back. Maybe that is why it's flapping.
Because there'll be watchers on that config map,
and it's just shutting down the API server.
There will, but he said it wasn't, which
means he's done something else
to the API server. Alright. Okay. I I
missed that. Okay. So grab dash v
less than watch.
We might be getting a new log.
Maybe.
Not yet.
It takes it takes a while. Does it
make useful comment
also?
You can take a look at in the
chat.
The one from Bala?
Yeah.
So Bala says, please check the identity tag
and the encryption config.
Okay.
And this?
Identities.
Or
Maybe
Google, like, identity and that CD encryption
config or something.
So you're telling me we've not fixed it.
Is that what you're saying?
Well, you did fix it for that one
one config map.
Alright. So I thought you were just being
curling the way to to to one thing.
Right? This this will be
you're right. This will be the key ID.
I'm actually making it pick up the key
or something.
Where's our API server? Hold on.
Yeah. Does it do crashly back off on
static ports? Because this is taking a long
time.
No.
The kiblet can just be a bit temperamental
at times. It can take up to, like,
four minutes.
You could always restart the kiblet.
Yeah.
There
we go. So k c m.
No. Alright. We're gonna have to fix this
properly then.
Or or hack doesn't work.
Okay. So, yeah, let's Google
guys that can fix it.
Interesting.
I mean,
it's encrypted.
It's very encrypted.
Okay. So we need to do that. If
you can you recreate that secret by, like,
using through KubeCTL?
Yes. So you what your suggestion is we
could do Yeah. Let's try and do that
first. System.
Yep.
System.
Root c a c r t o yaml
yaml.
And we can change this. Yeah. So I
never changed the matte as which probably break
it.
And apply.
What?
Alright. We need to learn how this encryption
Oh, apply. Yeah. Do a do just do
a delete. Just do a delete and a
create because if apply is trying to read
it to do a three way merge, and
it can't read it.
So
smash it. Hulk smash it. It didn't work
unless, I guess, we do an STD delete.
Well, you were trying to delete the file
you were trying to apply. Right? So that
will not work.
Right. Hey.
Okay. Great.
There we go. Oh, now the post. Okay.
So we need to encrypt everything or
do this identity hack to make it not
really Yeah. Let's let's do that identity thing
that we've talked about.
Alright. So we can
set encryption field type to identity.
Oh, that and, like, that kind of identity.
Okay. Do you know what that means? Do
you wanna go for it?
Oh, just as in it means, like like,
the identity function. Right? As in it means
just pass through and don't like, encryption type
identity just means don't do anything,
I guess.
But that doesn't make sense because a lot
of what's in XED is enciphered.
Right.
Except some of it wasn't.
Except some of it. But if we default
name space config maps weren't encrypted.
Right? Okay. You're saying we can get default
working again if we do this. We might
break some other stuff.
Right. So, like, if you Google,
like, HCD encryption config
or something. Oh, we could do it per
namespace. Okay.
I love if you Google for etcd. The
first hit is Kubernetes even if you don't
specify it. Okay. So there is an identity
right there.
Do I have that there?
No.
Right. So, basically, I encrypted all namespaces
except
default.
So it wasn't but because there was no
identity there, it wasn't able to read those
because they were not encrypted.
Oh, right. We needed an a configuration
and and resistant. The reason I did that
is because if you would decide to just
turn off encryption,
that would break the rest of the cluster.
Because then it would be able to read
that that namespace,
but then all of the control plane contain
maps will now work because they are now
encrypted
and would break the entire cluster. Okay. Found
that half encrypted half wasn't. That's that's clever.
So there's a much easier way than me
trying to retrofit the encryption then. Like, so
Yeah.
Which is clever because you basically just
so one one thing is if you recreate
the secret or the config map or whatever
resource,
then then
it will encrypt it using the EC config
and replace it. So that's why when you
use for cube root from the other namespace,
it worked.
Or you can just add that one line
identity in the config, and then now it's
able to read unencrypted stuff
by default.
Got it. Nice. I had I had no
idea that was a thing. So that's It
refuses to do no encryption. That's great, isn't
it? It refuses to do Well, I think
it's optional. Right? So stuff can be encrypted
or unencrypted.
I mean, maybe maybe they're not back. Yeah.
So if you have identity
in there, then it's both. Okay. So we
have four minutes, and we still need to
fix this Postgres. So Yeah.
So
I'm gonna cheat a little bit. He was
definitely messing with Cydium because there's some Cydium
config in in temp.
So Oh, that's me. That's part of the
customer bootstrap process, I believe. Okay.
Yeah. I I did not mess with Cyllium.
Because all of that Cyllium stuff flapped. Like,
the fact that the password is
wrong.
Okay. So the password is
correct here.
I think Postgres one two three is correct.
I believe the user is Postgres,
and the database is clustered.
In fact, our health check shows the user
Postgres.
So
And it's hard coded into the into the
Rust app, is it? It's not read for
the environment or anything you could fit into.
I should know, but I I I will
admit that
I wrote this a while back, and I've
abandoned that ever since. So
let's check.
Because my immediate thought again was was eBPF.
Right? I mean, what could make the password
be wrong, like an eBPF filter that's changing
it on the network?
No. The hardest thing was SCB encryption.
Everything else should be relatively
easier to fix.
I'm sure it's telling us some facts about
that. Yeah. And figure out.
I mean, it's weird because this is hard
coded.
Assuming it's our image,
which appears to be
password authentication failed for user postgres,
which means probably modify the stateful set. What's
the generation on this? Generation nine. Yeah.
I would I would have applied this once.
So Yeah.
I hate computers.
Yeah.
Well, I hate people too, so it's tricky,
isn't it?
I mean, that looks okay. PostgresQL one to
three.
It's not anything silly. Like, it's not Postgres
past w d or anything silly, is it?
I don't think so.
I mean so
this is a relatively stateless thing. Right?
So
he could have modified it in the pod.
I'm just gonna delete it and have the
database recreate.
Yeah. I I might be on our date
docs, but it looks like the environment variable
is called p g password, all one word.
Are you sure?
That's what I thought. I found some docs
that said that for the latest version.
But have you recreated it? Have you got
the original YAML sitting around? Can you just
recreate it? It didn't work. Oh, yeah. I
do have the original YAML.
Because a lot of what I did was
with kubectl edit. If you just thrown the
original YAML over the top of all the
you'd have fixed, like, six of my hacks
all at once.
Oh, don't do that.
Can we take a look at the YAML
again in the cluster?
Oh, it is. Postgre password. Okay.
That's what those docs are all about.
Okay. Let's work this out.
Okay. Stable set. No choice default.
Keep scrolling down.
Oh, you son of a
Oh, what?
Oh, man.
In the start up That's great.
Nice.
Very nice. You made me laugh out loud.
Like it. Our APIs never flapped.
Oh, yeah. We still haven't got to the
bottom of that. So what causes pods to
restart?
Health checks?
Interesting.
Yeah. So,
like, Kube API server and Kube scheduler and
those, they have health checks. Right?
Right.
I mean, lots of things. Right? I mean,
you could've been you could've been making a
note already. You could've caused the thing to
exit one because it doesn't like its config
file. But, yeah, health checks
also.
Is it possible that the health check is
not healthy for some reason?
It's doing HTTPS.
Is this
I could have believed it was because it
needed the CA bundle to be able to
to verify the service certificate of the API
server, but that's back now. Yeah. I don't
think lives use the real endpoint, is it?
Is that what you changed?
I actually think it No? It I think
it is. Yeah. I don't look enough at
this. Every time I see it, I'm like,
that can't be right. I mean, like, yeah,
it's probably gonna be, like, hard to there's
just a small little change. I mean, it
go up.
So there is where
is it? None of us access. False.
Right. Yeah.
Okay. So
yeah. So it's making the the health check
fail.
That's nice actually because that's honestly, like, an
error a user could make. Because if you're
if you're installing your own cluster, you see
something like that, and, of course, you turn
it off. Like, it's it's actually a very
Yeah. You're like, oh, I don't possible thing
to, yeah, to get wrong.
Awesome.
I think that should be it. Should that
be all of it?
We're We never actually go to edit our
Postgres.
Oh, you gotta okay. And you gotta restart
failed. Yeah.
Oh, I don't think you took enough. The
API server died before I could save the
alter.
I don't think you're taking enough lines out
of that. Have a look at the indentation
again.
Let's try again.
Oh, yeah. You're right. My whole idea was
that you would fix this first
and then try to recreate the pod, but
because this pod uses config map in this
namespace, it would fail.
And then you'll have to go figure out
what's going on with HCD.
That was a hard one, I gotta say.
We still haven't fixed it.
Oh, Postgres. HTTP. Yeah.
Why does it not when I changed the
spec?
Oh, you need to, yeah, you need to
kill it. Right? Yeah.
I shouldn't have. Not when I changed the
stateful set.
Oh, yeah. I did the stateful set. I
should have rolled it.
Well, unless someone changed the semantics. There we
go. There we go. We're two minutes late,
but we did get the dense. You were.
Not not bad.
Alright. Those were
two really tough clusters, I gotta say.
HCD is always I've had the AppArmor HCD,
never things I like to see.
So
that was a tough one, Rawkode.
And that was that was very good. I
thought I'd squeeze the SCD. That's why I
squeezed the CPU. Right? Because I'm like, SCD
is just when it goes wrong, you never
know how to fix it. So I thought
if I could just make it sort of
misbehave,
sort of be really slow and annoying,
everybody's just gonna be like, oh, SCD. I
don't understand it.
Because it's always the thing that gives you
cold sweats when you see the spam. Yeah.
Because how often do you have to use
STD control? Like, never. Right? Really?
Yeah. I did need the backup of it.
There's a hints folder.
Was there a Hints folder? Damn it. Yeah.
There was a backup of XCD completely unencrypted,
and there was a backup of
there was the the YAML file for
the encryption configuration with the identity in there.
So just in case we got lost,
we could do fix those. In case some
idiot starts writing random bytes to EdCT, yeah,
you really could better keep it back up.
Yeah. Well, I did it for me because
I was doing stupid things with EdCT.
Alright. Well,
thank you both for for joining us today.
Those were great. Those are really good. You
know what? It's it's the best episodes are
the ones where I walk away confused but
learning so much, and I got that from
both of your customers. So I really appreciate
the effort you've put in there and for
joining me during the debugging as well.
Thank you to the audience for watching us,
and all your comments. They're always very helpful.
These are always one step ahead of us,
and, thank you to Teleport for sponsoring clustered.
We will be back next week with more
broken clusters and more pain for me, Pop.
If you're still watching, you definitely all Barco
that that gift card there. You definitely destroyed
that.
Alright. Any final words before I say goodbye
to you both for today?
It's fine. Thanks a lot. I'm honored to
be here.
Yeah. No. Same. And thanks thanks for the
breakage. I lots of stuff as well. Alright.
Have a wonderful day. Enjoy your weekend. Thanks
a lot. Bye all.